so my name is nura I currently work as a
research scientist at neurocat which is
a startup in Berlin that focuses on
Safety and Security of artificial
intelligence so I spend a lot of my time
thinking about the problems with
artificial intelligence
specifically the problems that keep us
from being able to use it on safety or
security critical applications for
example autonomous driving or using
artificial intelligence for medical
decisions
and one problem that I'm particularly
passionate about is the explainability
problem in other words that models that
we use to make decisions are not so
comprehendable by us and the decisions
that they make themselves do not always
come with explanations
and in recent literature
in recent literature there has been an
explosion of papers in the domain of
explainable AI and it's a very popular
topic that I'm sure you've heard about
but explainable AI has not solved the
explainability problem yet at least not
completely and the focus of this talk
will be about the explainability problem
so first I'll talk about what is the
problem and why is it worth considering
then I'll talk about reasons why it's
still an open problem and finally I'll
talk about future of legislation and how
legislation will shape how the
explainability problem is supposed to
evolve
and so we'll start with talking about
the problem so what exactly is
explainability
well as I mentioned before we're using
machine learning models that are
considered black Bots it's a common term
used in the literature and the idea is
this we can have input data we can put
it into a model and get a prediction as
an output and we don't necessarily know
how the model arrives at its decisions
and so one can say okay but why do we
really care if it's for example a model
that classifies cats from dogs is it so
important that we know how it works
well we don't always need to know but
when it's making decisions that are
critical so for instance if you input
your CV into a model and it outputs a
prediction that you are not a suitable
candidate for this job you will want an
explanation
and the Crux of the explainability
problem I believe is that as a result
there is a lack of trust in artificial
intelligence and if we want to really
reach the full potential of artificial
intelligence we have to be able to trust
its decisions
and so let's look at this data scientist
he says Ah I have a solution
here it shows that we are optimizing for
predictive accuracy we've developed
these black box models in response to
our need for highly accurate large-scale
models why don't we just change the
objective function we can penalize it
and say no we only want to use models
that are simpler that come with an
explanation and he has a good idea
however we found that in general there
is a trade-off between explainability
and accuracy that we can get and now I
want to say this comes with caveats this
diagram is quite popular but it's not
always the case so for instance linear
models and decision trees are considered
to be transparent or explainable because
by Design we know how they work for
instance decision trees partition the
feature space so we can know for a
particular prediction exactly how it
arrived at its result
on the other hand we have ensembles
which is just a collection of models
that vote and we have deep neural
networks and these models tend to have
very high predictive accuracy on complex
tasks such as image classification but
by their design they are not always
explainable and indeed there are cases
where linear models are not explainable
so for example if you heavily transform
your features and you get regression
coefficients on those transform features
they might not be so directly
explainable and also sometimes linear
models are as accurate as neural
networks in some applications but in
general we do have to sacrifice
explainability when we get predictive
accuracy at a large scale
and so our data scientist has returned
and he says oh but okay that's not so
good but why does my model even need to
be explainable because I trust it
and that's good in many cases we can
trust our models but still want an
explanation and while there's a lot
written here I'll just give the basics
so we can explain to justify a decision
in the previous example if your CV is
rejected you will want the justification
for that we can explain to control so if
our model is faulty on certain decisions
we can see an explanation and see how we
can fix the model and we can even
explain to discover new associations
this is quite an interesting idea that
explanations teach us what we haven't
been able to see ourselves in a large
data setting
however I think that this quote
summarizes really what is the demand for
interpretability which is the demand for
interpretability arises when there is a
mismatch between the formal objectives
of supervised learning and the real
world costs in a deployment setting
and I'll give some concrete examples of
when we want explanation so here's a
really fascinating example about medical
Discovery some scientists at UC San
Francisco have built a model that will
predict whether a patient will cost a
lot or not a lot or even pretty close to
the actual cost that a patient will have
just from chest x-rays and that's
extremely useful but
what is it about this x-ray that will
make a patient expensive if we use what
is shown Below in red a saliency map or
a heat map the red areas correspond to
the parts of the image that are most
instructive to the model we can say hmm
maybe this expensive patients have this
red area in the top left corner let's
investigate that and see what kind of
associations we can learn
another reason for explainability is
adversarial settings and this is not
talked about as much but at neurocat we
really focus a lot on adversarial
security so
deep neural networks have another flaw
in that they are deeply uh they're
perceptible to small shifts in the
inputs they're very fragile actually so
I'll give an example we look on the
bottom that there are two images of a
panda bear now we as humans see them as
panda bears it looks like the same image
in fact the image on the right has been
perturbed very slightly in a specific
manner such that a classifier that will
classify this as a panda the image on
the left will classify the image on the
right as a gibbon which is a different
animal and we say okay so what there's a
mistake we don't see this as a panda
well okay but what about in the settings
of autonomous vehicles let's look at
this stop sign what if somebody puts
this reflective sticker on a stop sign
as a human being driving on the road
maybe we don't notice it because we
still recognize the stop sign maybe a
self-driving car will not and one can
imagine what kind of catastrophe can
happen if a self-driving car makes a
mistake when a passenger is present
and so explainability comes into play
here because we can check whether a
model is behaving in line with its
concept if it's conceptually sound is
the self-driving car recognizing traffic
signs for the right reasons or is it
relying rather on spurious correlations
and if we know that then we can see how
we can make our model more robust so
indeed explainability has its reasons
Beyond just trusting the model it can
also save lives
and so now that we've talked quite a lot
about the need for explainability let's
see what Solutions we have so as I
mentioned before there is a plethora of
methods that we can use some methods are
very specific to certain problems some
methods are more General and for the
remainder of the talk I would like to
focus on methods that are post hoc
meaning that you've already trained the
model and you want to get an explanation
from this trained model
and they tend to be model agnostic as
well so it's also good to focus on
methods that are off the shelf so if you
have a model you want to get an
explanation and these are the most
popular Methods at the moment
and so our data scientist comes back for
a final time and he says okay great I
know about this post-hoc explanation
method called lime and I have a model
can I not just apply line to my model
get out some explanations and call it a
day
no he cannot or not in every case at
least because there are some problems
with explainable AI and in this part I'd
like to talk about the open problems
that are remaining in explainability and
why explainability has not been
completely solved by these explainable
AI methods and as a caveat there are
certain methods that have been created
for very specific problems that do a
good job but the general methods and
typically the post-hoc methods that
people tend to trust and rely on without
thinking too much beforehand can be
problematic and I'll give some examples
so one problem that we have is there's a
gap in interpretation so the
interpretability Gap meaning that we can
get an explanation using an
off-the-shelf method such as a saliency
map here but a human being still has to
decide what does it mean so for instance
here from a paper we have a
convolutional neural network that takes
us input chest x-rays and predicts
whether the person has pneumonia and
here this particular x-ray is predicted
with 85 percent confidence that they
have pneumonia and along with the
prediction comes an explanation in the
form of a saliency map and as in before
the red areas indicate areas that
contributed the most to the model's
decision
okay now we can show the saliency map to
a radiologist or to another medical
practitioner and they say well this
could mean several things maybe it's
about the heart shape maybe it's about
the pulmonary artery or maybe there was
even an issue with the X-ray maybe there
was
um some noise in it and it actually is
not correct
the point is that we still need a
radiologist to interpret this and so we
say maybe the saliency map isn't
fulfilling its promise it's not
providing an explanation that we can act
on and of course this depends on how we
Define our objective what kind of
explanation do we really want for whom
by whom so the Gap that we have is that
we still need human beings to provide
some interpretations and while in some
cases such as Radiology we have
Radiologists let's consider Auto ml in
the future perhaps we have completely
automated systems where we start with
raw data and we get out prediction and
explanation and it goes in the hands of
a patient
the patient needs to be able to see and
directly understand what actions to take
from explanations and when there's a gap
this ambiguity can cause some problems
and another problem that comes with
explainability is this evaluation
problem so we need to actually be able
to know how explainable is an explainer
which sounds a bit strange to say
especially given that explainability is
not a quantitative subject really it's
more qualitative we do need to be able
to measure it and as I will talk about a
little bit later this has a lot to do
with legislation because if we demand
interpretability and we want to claim
that our model is interpretable
we're going to have to be able to
measure how interpretable it is the
problem that we have now is that there's
no standard way of doing it and there
are several papers that propose metrics
and there are individual papers that
have come up with explainability methods
and have done user surveys so it's not
that we aren't measuring it at all it's
just that there needs to be some sort of
standard metric for comparison how do we
know if shop is more explainable than
lime in this particular case and these
are two examples of explainability
methods and so here's an idea is that we
can have this Black Box model from our
previous slide it gives us a prediction
and an explanation but then we have to
think of this target Persona so we have
different people who need an explanation
so a doctor a patient a business
stakeholder who needs to be convinced
that investing in this model is worth it
and so we need to be able to evaluate
the opinions of all of these people with
user studies and say okay how well do
you understand what do you understand
from this explanation what actions do
you want to take and with these results
we can then improve our explanation
method for the specific problem
and so the problem is we're just not
there yet and once we establish standard
metrics for measuring explainability
then we can more easily choose an
explanation method for a certain problem
or it can help us come up with new
methods that are more in line with the
problem
and finally a problem that we really
need to discuss is the disagreement
problem in other words that
state-of-the-art post-hoc explanation
methods have been found to disagree
in terms of explanations they output on
the same prediction
and so I give an example from a paper
from Krishna at all in 2022 so this is
very recent
and so the authors use the compass
algorithm which is an algorithm that is
predicting recidivism or whether a
person who has previously committed a
crime will commit another crime and this
algorithm has come under quite a bit of
scrutiny in terms of its fairness
especially towards minorities
and so if you're using an algorithm to
decide whether a person will go back to
prison this can impact how a judge
decides the sentence and so this is
extremely sensitive
and so in this case it goes without
saying that we need some explanation if
a defendant is predicted to be someone
who would return to prison this is
something fair this is something that a
person has right to and so the authors
you look at the compass data set which
has seven features here and they plot
feature importances from the model using
different explainers so feature
importance plot just shows to what
degree has a feature contributed to the
decision so this is one from an
individual decision suppose we have an
individual who is predicted to be likely
to return to prison and a judge thinks
okay maybe I will want to put a harsher
sentence on this person
then we want to know why and on the left
we have lime which is a method of
post-hoc explanation and we have kernel
shap which is just another state of the
art method
and we find that there's disagreement so
on top we have the person's age lime
says that H has a large contribution to
the decision in a positive direction but
Colonel shop says no actually it's not a
large contribution and it's in the
negative Direction
and then if we look at the bottom there
is the candidate's race where line says
that race contributes to a small degree
but criminal shop says it's to a larger
degree
and now the question is which one do we
listen to because both are telling us
conflicting things especially on the
topic of race because if race is a
significant contributor then we question
the fairness of this algorithm on this
individual
the problem is that we have to ask data
scientists what do they do so if you're
a data scientist and you encounter a
disagreement what are you going to do
and the authors actually conducted some
user studies and they asked questions
such as this one which is okay given
that you find that these disagree which
one will you choose and they ask these
kind of questions to users and they
found that around 86 percent of users
said that when they encounter the
disagreement problem they either don't
know what to do with it or they choose
an arbitrary method so maybe I will
choose lime just because I know how it
works or I've used it before or I just
like it better
and so in the large scale maybe when
you're a data scientist looking at
metrics for an entire data set maybe at
the moment you don't think it's such a
critical decision but then when you look
at one individual
the decision of the explainer will
determine the reasons for why this
person is predicted to
to have likelihood of committing a crime
for that one individual it matters
greatly and so this quote says it quite
well that you could have many
explanations for what a complex model is
doing do you just pick the one that you
want to be correct because indeed human
bias also has to do with this and the
problem is at the moment it seems that
this is the solution that we have
and of course again literature is
responding to the disagreement problem
it's identifying it in other domains for
instance another paper recently
identified it in education but there's
still no standard rule for what to do
about this
and this has a lot to do with
establishing explainability standards so
now we go to the more legal side of
things
so in the near future the European Union
is expected to release the artificial
intelligence act which is a set of laws
that have the goal of regulating the
development of artificial intelligence
applications in a way such that there
will be increased trust in its adoption
and something to be clear about this
first of all that it's not yet the law
of the land so it's still being created
and if you were to go to the website of
this EU AI act they are providing a lot
of information also quite a lot of
information about where there's weakness
in the current legislation at least the
proposed legislation
and their goal is not to ban artificial
intelligence in fact regulation is
always a bit controversial for the tech
industry but the EU doesn't want to say
no more artificial intelligence but they
want to make sure that it's trustworthy
and what they do is they divide
applications into risk categories so
some risks are unacceptable other risks
are just high risk so for example this
CV screening model this would be high
risk because its output decides whether
or not you get an interview for a job
and then all the other applications are
considered other and they're actually
going to be left less regulated so it's
not going to be an extremely strict act
except for the high security High safety
applications
and so then what is the euai act going
to say about explainability
this could change but from Article 13 we
can get the following information so
first that it's going to be quantifiable
in that it has to be a high risk AI
system shall be designed and developed
in a way to ensure that their operation
is sufficiently transparent so
sufficiently transparent means there has
to be some measure of transparency and
explainability metrics can provide that
next it's to enable users to interpret
the system's output and use it
appropriately so user empowering and
going back to the example of the
saliency map and the radiologist having
to use it an explanation has to be
enabling the user to use the results of
this model and make decisions
finally it's supposed to be compliance
oriented in that in the future we can
Envision that there's going to be some
rules about your AI system has to comply
with and explainability is going to be
key to ensuring compliance because if
you have a model that is explainable to
a certain degree that can prove that you
are compliant with the law
and so here are some final thoughts
about this first of all as regulation is
going to happen
we can see that explanation is going to
be necessary we have to think about the
problem from now and I've collected a
few opinions because there are several
differing opinions and I want to share
them with you so first
let us insist that we do not use Black
Box machine learning models for
high-stakes decisions unless no
interpretable model can be constructed
that achieves the same level of accuracy
it is possible that an interpretable
model can always be constructed we just
have not been trying perhaps if we did
we would never use black boxes for these
high-stakes decisions at all and this is
from Cynthia Rudin and Joanna rotten so
I have previously quoted Cynthia Rudin
so this is one opinion do away with
black boxes we're not trying hard enough
we've come up with explainable models in
the past you can look at the field of
statistics for this
we are relying on these models because
we are lazy and instead we should just
change how we build models that's one
opinion
now is it applicable to everything
that's a question people have agreements
or disagreements on this but one way of
looking at explainability is that we're
building the models wrong
and now let's look at the opinion of
someone else who's a doctor and he's
speaking from the field of Medicine
and he says instead of his name is
Anthony Chang he says instead of
requiring local explanations from a
complicated AI system we should advocate
for thorough and rigorous validation of
these systems across as many diverse and
distinct populations as possible showing
that patients and Healthcare outcomes
are improved and that marginalized
groups are not disproportionately
affected by Any Given system so his
concern is fairness that in medicine and
Healthcare we want to ensure that
algorithms are fair meaning that they
perform as accurately on groups of
concern or across different groups of
concern so an example would be a
predictive algorithm for whether a
patient has pneumonia Works equally well
for women as it does for men and
currently some algorithms are not
performing equally across these groups
and so with this opinion
the idea is that local explanations are
not going to solve the problem exactly
rather we need to collect better data
and we need to validate our model across
these different data sets and so the
opinion of Dr Anthony Chang is not that
explanation is is necessary it's that
the data is the problem
so first we have computer scientists who
believe that the models are the problem
we shouldn't use black boxes next we
have someone who says well
explainability local explanations
they're not gonna
really solve the problem and black box
models shouldn't be done away with it's
rather that we need to use better data
and if we use the right data Black Box
models are going to perform fairly and
they will give us High utility
and now we come at a final opinion which
is
the issue of explainability is really
centered on the trust not only of
artificial intelligence tools but also
on those clinicians and data scientists
who espouse and Advocate the use of
these tools
perhaps we will all settle eventually in
the diminutive Sweet Spot between
interpretability and accuracy versus
explainability and a new paradigm of
what is trustworthy and acceptable will
be introduced with sufficient alignment
validation and equity and this is from a
paper called the false hope of current
approaches to explainable artificial
intelligence in healthcare so the title
does say a bit about the opinion of the
authors but
indeed this is a very interesting quote
because
the authors do not say that it's about
the model they don't say it's about the
data they say it's about how we trust
them and that perhaps in the future
there's going to be a new way of
trusting
and it's interesting to look at this
because consider current use of mobile
phones or social media
one can say that the younger generation
that's born with these tools is a lot
more trusting than older Generations
that know life without these tools and
perhaps the future Generations that are
born with artificial intelligence being
used in high security applications might
never question whether they can trust it
or they just have a different way of
trusting it that we can have a future
where for instance we have the output of
algorithms and the Radiologists
interpreting it and we have a
combination of artificial intelligence
with explanations and a human being
or we provide different kind of
explanations so that the user can choose
the one that they understand the most
but we can decide ourselves what do we
trust and what expectations do we have
so again three different opinions
there's the models there's the data and
then there's us how do we trust it and
what kind of systems do we build
how do we work with artificial
intelligence such that we combine The
Best of Both Worlds the computational
efficiency and predictive ability of
artificial intelligence and also the
human touch and human intuition and
experience
and so I'd like to conclude with just
this that if there's anything that can
be taken away from this talk it's that
explainability is very much an open
problem
and perhaps for many of you this is
obvious but
when we look at the popularity of
off-the-shelf explainers we look at how
easy it is in a few lines of code to
take a model that you've trained get an
explanation out of it and then call your
model explainable it seems that there is
a belief that explainability is solved
by popular explainable AI methods and
it's not
and indeed currently There's an
opportunity to solve this problem if you
have an application that's going to be
deployed in high security
domain or even if it's not a high
security domain if you want to have
users trust your application then now is
the time to focus on explainability and
invest in coming up with a solution that
works for your domain and solving this
problem is a necessary step towards
realizing the goal of safe and
trustworthy artificial intelligence
thank you and I'll take your questions
thank you very much
um
classifying the history picture and
basically so when you when you told this
I was thinking how actually the doctor
is kept doing the same thing and the
doctor uses it I guess would take it's
outcome like any other aspects
history of the patient and build some
sort of mental model of importance
and so I was thinking maybe you have
come across any of ways or approaches
building the models in such a way that
it somehow reflects the reality a bit
more and then explainability is kind of
baked into it in such a way that people
can reason about it so it's not just a
function that matched one data to the
label but somehow is like
having Encounters in your cannabis
gorgeous in this area
so very good question so indeed there I
cannot come up with specific
Publications off the top of my head but
I have of course encountered approaches
towards explainability that's either an
intrinsic part of the model or a
different kind of explanation methods
besides saliency maps that provide a
more uh well-rounded explanation to
doctors and to patients and indeed that
try to mimic the way a radiologist who
has been trained for years would provide
an explanation or would make a decision
so this example is quite particular to
this paper and quite particular to
saliency Maps so indeed there has been
and currently is movement in this
direction of course sometimes there is a
cost of predictive accuracy that comes
with this but indeed people are working
on it so I'm not claiming that this is
the only way that interpretations come
about it's just that this is the way
that's most accessible to people and
it's much easier to to just apply a
saliency map then to invest in coming up
with a specific solution and so I use
this example just to show that the
off-the-shelf explainers that we have
right now have this Gap but indeed if
you are a medical practitioner if you're
a researcher that really wants to come
up with the right solution then they
will have to come up with a specific
explainability method either
intrinsically in the model or post-hoc
or even a combination that will more
reflect how the decision is being made
but this is very difficult so
that's uh that's the challenge
hello here yes thank you very much I
really was very very interesting uh high
quality overview
um I I feel like there is a stress point
uh between especially in legislation
between being uh realistic and kind of
having the highest possible standards
you know this being uh
exponential technology moving fast and
requires something different as you know
from other fields
so um just as a pretext of the question
I work with Dr Robin yampolski he works
at AIC security and he has papers um
explainability things like that
one of his thesis is uh are about how
just like how it's hard for a human to
explain to a squirrel nuclear fusion the
Gap is too large
and that there are things that uh
supremely Advanced AI will simply not be
able to explain to us because we won't
have maybe the capacity to do it
um I would say in that vein do you agree
with this line of thinking do we have to
sort of uh surrender to the higher level
of intelligence that it will provide and
just be okay with a more General
incomplete exclamation uh you know this
is a more long-term question
but just how do you view the Horizon of
explainability if that makes sense
yes it makes sense it's a very big
question that you're asking and thank
you for asking it so indeed as you said
um The interpretability Gap is very
large in some applications and there are
even some people who argue that for
example if you ask me why did you why
did you come here
I don't always have a logical
explanation for everything that I do and
there are multiple explanations or even
better ask a kid why did you take your
sister's toy the kid is not gonna give
you logical step-by-step reasons there's
just sometimes the human brain doesn't
even have explanations for what we do
and some people argue look at these
examples humans can't explain themselves
so rationally why do we care that
artificial intelligence does and indeed
there's another argument that the
utility of these very Advanced systems
will be so great that maybe we will have
to sacrifice some explainability and as
you say surrender to it so my opinion on
this I think I can't have a general
opinion because it's so application
specific I mean will you be willing to
surrender to the almighty reasoning of a
self-driving car
if it's the only way to get from A to B
maybe you will
or maybe you won't if you're an
experienced driver who says no I trust
myself much more so I would say that
this is quite a big question and my
answer would just be that it really
really depends a lot on the on the
domain and then depends on the user so I
don't really have a concrete answer I
think with time going back to the last
quote that I shared about the new
paradigm of trust perhaps that will be a
part of it once we have a new paradigm
of trust the Next Generation maybe we'll
answer this we'll see to what degree
will people in general be willing to
accept the high performance of
artificial intelligence without fully
understanding it
and then the rest is just very personal
opinions depending on the person
depending on the application and another
thing is that trust is a very individual
thing and so if it's down to trust then
this is something that each of us will
have to answer and legislation will
somehow have to come up with an answer
as well I'm not from this domain so I
don't envy these people who have to do
it
thank you for representation
so my question is to call date first
some of these Sai techniques like the
Shadow the line are very difficult even
before the machine learning engineer to
understand
so it kind of sounds counter-intuitive
that those techniques provide an
explanation
so and a user or not as project is not
you know machine learning it would be
much harder for them to understand even
like how the shepherd values work how
would you address this
contributed intuitive part of it and the
next question is the future importance
why is that considering an xci technique
like the regression model does provide
an explanation and the relationship
between the input features and the
targets but that's not considered an Sai
like or explanation so why do you think
that xai Community like is embracing
this equation importance
explanation thank you
okay so thank you for the questions
those are really good questions and
we'll take some time to answer so the
first part if I recall correctly so the
first part is that okay these methods
such as shop so there's sharply values
by their definition but then there's
sharply additive explanations there's
kernel shop there's many variations of
this and that many machine learning
practitioners might not know exactly the
mathematical definitions and not be able
to really understand how you get these
shapley values but you can implement it
in a few lines of code and so there is a
paradox that even the people who are
supposed to understand how these methods
work can use them without understanding
and then we use those to explain to
people who are maybe less involved with
the model and might not understand so
two things so first there is the actual
mechanism for how we get an explanation
and then there is the output which is
the explanation itself so for instance
the method of shop or shapley values
this is something that will require some
reading to understand I do believe I
would be quite concerned if data
scientists are not able to learn how it
works because I think we should focus on
methods that do have some mathematical
foundation and sharply values do at
least in Game Theory economics
mathematics so maybe focusing on
developing methods that are grounded in
mathematics is the first step
and the explanation itself though
doesn't involve as much mathematics so
we can use sharply values to get out
feature importance and so the
explanation itself it tends to be
something simpler and indeed it does
have to come with some text and we do
have to teach human beings how to read
the chart so
it's correct that there is no magic
bullet that we just get an explanation
that is instantly comprehensible by
everyone and that the methods that we
use to get these explanations are all so
simple that every data scientist who is
not a mathematician necessarily will
understand it yeah that's not the case
indeed and what I would do to address it
is first of all focus on developing
methods that have mathematical
foundation and second focus on getting
explanations that are in its simplest
form and that goes back to getting user
studies and really learning from
different kind of users how they see
these explanations and in what format is
most useful and one interesting paper
that I read recently proposed a
surrogate model so this is one kind of
explanation but the outputs of that
specifically for the domain of insurance
are in the form of an Excel table that
will provide in numbers and words such
that people working in financial
Industries can very easily understand
this and even export it to excel which
is a very popular tool that they use so
it would be
focusing on making sure that the method
is understandable by the data scientist
and that the output is understandable by
the specific domain by conducting user
studies so that's the first question and
so the second question
I have to recall what exactly it was
about why
yeah that's also a very good
um that's a good question so why feature
importance because as you correctly
state with linear regression models we
get the weights of the coefficients that
it assigns to the features and that is
in a way already interpretable and so
why is that suddenly a new xai method
well I would argue that linear models
are in fact considered by the xai
community as a way to explain so
oftentimes you would fit a local linear
model and then use those coefficients to
get an explanation so it's just a tool
it's it's a method but I think a reason
why it's very nice is that linear models
have a beautiful mathematical definition
and Foundation quite easy to understand
and why the focus on feature importance
I think that it has been found to be
quite intuitive for an end user that if
you see these bar charts
for instance here
a user can know that something that's
red contributes negative something blue
contributes positive and that magnitude
has to the size of the bar would have to
do with the magnitude and so this is
something perhaps that's even coming
from our elementary school education in
mathematics and statistics so I think
the reason why we focus a lot on feature
importance even though it's not always
accurate as you see there's a
disagreement already with two methods
it's just something that's easily
understood by people and so a really
good point is that we're sacrificing
some of the accuracy of the explanations
is so that people can understand them in
a way that we have been taught to
understand charts from our education and
that's another thing to think about is
don't rely so much on something that's
so easily explainable but then on the
other hand if it's not easily understood
by people then what's what's the purpose
so very good questions that you bring up
and unfortunately no clear answers to
either of them
any other questions